on your better days
when you see a positive future what do
you think is the way out
of this uh chaos of 2020 like if you
visualize at 2025
that's a better world than today what is
that how do we get there and what does
that look like
it's a good question
i can honestly say i don't know
and uh i wouldn't have said i don't know
a year ago
a year ago i would have said we're going
to be okay as much as people hate trump
the upon
economy is doing great i think we're
going to be fine that's not
how i feel today today uh i don't think
there's uh
a clear solution politically because i
think if trump wins
people going to be furious and i think
if biden wins people going to be furious
um particularly like if things get more
woke
you know if people uh continue to
enforce
this uh forced compliance and make
people
behave a certain way and act a certain
way which seems to be a part of what
this whole woke thing is that
is the most disturbing for me is that i
see what's going on i see
there's a lot of losers that have hopped
on this
and they they shove it in people's faces
and it doesn't have to make sense like
there was a black lives matter protest
that stopped this woman
at a restaurant uh they were surrounding
her outside a restaurant they were
forcing her to raise her fist
in compliance this is a woman who's
marched for black lives
multiple times black lives matter
multiple times and the people all around
her doing this were all white
yeah it's all it's all weird my friend
coach t he's a wrestling coach is also
uh
on a podcast my friend brian moses his
take on it is that black and he's a
black guy he says black lives matter's a
white cult
and i'm like when you see that picture
it's hard to argue that he's got a point
i mean it's clearly not all about that
but there's a lot of people that have
jumped on board that are very much like
cult members
because the thing about black lives
matter or any movement
is you can't control who joins
there's no entrance examination so you
don't go okay how do you feel about this
what's your perceptions on that like
how you like the the man who shot the
trump supporter
in portland you know that guy who uh
murdered the trump supporter then the
cop shot him
that guy was walking around with his
hand
on his gun looking for trump supporters
just want i mean he's a
known violent guy who was walking around
looking for trump supporters found one
and shot one
that has nothing to do with black lives
matter he's a white guy he shot another
white guy it's just
it's just madness you know and that kind
of madness
is uh it's disturbing to see it
ramp up so quickly i mean there's been
there's been riots in portland every
night
oh excuse me demonstrations for 101 days
now 101 days in a row of them lighting
things on fire breaking into federal
buildings
it's like whoever saw that coming nobody
saw that coming so
i don't know what the solution is and i
don't know what it looks
like in five years so 2025 to answer
your question like
it could be anything i mean we could be
looking at mad max we could be looking
at
the apocalypse we could we could also be
looking at an invasion from another
country we could
be looking at a war like a real hot war
you